- My name's Tommy Dunne
and I'm the weapons master
on HBO, Game of Thrones.
Everyone tells me it's the
coolest job in the world
and I say it's the one
with the biggest headache.
But no, it's cool, it's
mainly down to myself,
what the look and design is
and the feel of all the weaponry.
And again, I never look and
never chase up the image
that George had in his books,
because I didn't want to be persuaded by
his feel or his interpretation,
I like my feel of it and my
interpretation of what it is.
- How did you make Beric
Dondarrion's flaming sword?
- That's a combination between ourselves
and the special effects team,
because obviously I made and
designed the original one,
which was quite a basic sword,
nothing fancy about it, the Beric one,
but then obviously the
special effects team
had to come up with a
procedure of lighting it,
so they made an internal gas
system into a hollow sword
and then we just supplied
all the cross guards
on with the hand piece,
so they would make a gas rig
and they would make a, basically a sword
that was impregnated
with a lighting liquid,
that could be lit by flame,
so it would keep alight
for, about half a minute
and I think it was simple enough,
the physical one that they fought with,
but the gas one was a bit intricate.
To ignite it and to turn it off,
but the effects (team) did a
very, very good job, good lads.
The Oathkeeper was the tricky one.
Making sure it looked like what it was,
using jewels like Swarovski crystals.
Needle was a nice one
because it was one of those
things where obviously,
she's a very young girl.
At that stage I think
Maisie was only like 12, 13.
And she was a very petite girl.
So we know that the
weapon would have to be
some sort of file or that
kind of scenario where
being a needle, it was
exactly what the name said.
It looks like a needle.
It's quite a natural small little sword.
And it hasn't changed,
the holder hasn't changed.
It's all as is, obviously she's grown up,
not a lot but she's grown up.
So the sword has kept with her,
it's the same.
We've never had to play with it.
Actually she's always been good with it,
considering how she fights.
She fights left-handed but
she's actually right-handed.
They're dangerous enough at the same time,
I mean, the hero ones for example,
will be a tougher weld
with the steel blades.
We'd never fight with them
but we'd always have them
for the hero feel, the hero look.
We always then make an
aluminium version of the blade.
We'll make a bamboo version and
we'll make a rubber version.
So we have all the
components that will be safe.
So anybody fights will
be bamboo on bamboo,
will be rubber on rubber,
will be aluminium on aluminium
and we never mix and match
the different blades.
There are so many
different looks and styles
that are brought into the tales.
Absolute probably, 10,000,
15,000 different types,
depending on what the weapon would be.
If it's a principal weapon,
you'd have a couple of hero ones.
You'd have four or five fighting swords.
And again six or eight safety swords.
So we make sure everybody's
a bit safe on set.
Fight or if you have to ride horses
that's when we have rubber
scabbards, rubber swords
so everybody walks away.
Some of our actors are very strong,
so what happens is that
they just keep hammering
and hammering so hard.
They suddenly realize
when they have bamboo,
that they can move faster.
And with some of our
training regimes for example,
we had Pod and Brienne fighting.
That's a scenario where we had
to make sure that there was
a bit of bamboo to try and slow down
and take the power away from Brienne.
Especially that Gwendoline
is a strong girl and
puts a lot of power into it.
So we just had to try and find a way
of pulling that power back a little bit.
The problem with an aluminium sword
or even a wooden sword
is that's really gonna hit
hard onto another sword.
But when you're fighting with a bamboo,
you'll find that less is more with them.
So it actually does slow them
down a bit with the power.
- I would imagine maybe in
the Battle of the Bastards,
there's a bamboo sword in there somewhere.
- There's a battlefield
of swords in that one.
A lot of rubber,
there's none in that one.
It will be the best season ever.
Nothing would surpass this.
- I woke my deaf grandmother
screaming at the television.
So if it's going to be better than that.
I'm really excited.
- I think you'll wake up
a few ancestors this year,
next year when it next comes out,
not only your granny.